- [Edward] Thank you
everyone for coming out today
and spending a few minutes
with Sunil and myself.
Again, my name is Edward McIlheran.
I'm with Kyndryl.
I'm a consult partner
with our digital workplace
services practice.
I'm focused primarily on contact
center modernization across
all of our different verticals,
including healthcare, state
and local government, financial
services, and many more.
- Hi, I'm Sunil Menon.
I am a senior business development leader
for customer experience
engagement in US healthcare
at AWS.
- There we go. So a little QR code.
We'll have this slide up at the very end,
but again, if you guys want
to hang out afterwards,
we'll be here for the next half hour
to discuss any questions
that you may have stemming
from today's presentation.
So the short of our presentation
today is how can we help
you engage your patients during
the entire episode of care
and beyond leveraging the power of AI?
And I get it, that AI
is the number one thing
happening in our industry.
Everybody's looking to
AI, how do we use it
to solve our key use cases
and really drive home
a lot of benefits for our organization.
And so today we're gonna focus
on kind of like, three themes
that, and I'll talk about here shortly,
and you'll see that
throughout the deck as well,
of how does this apply
to patient engagement
and what are the opportunities
to leverage AI in the
contact center space.
So number one is with the
consumerization of it,
we're seeing a lot of
this chat bot experiences,
the ChatGPTs of the world
are, everybody has access to,
and it's really revolutionizing the way
that you can interact with data.
And so now the consumers have the need to,
or the preference of having
this from the services
they consume, including healthcare.
So it really opens up the opportunity
to reimagine those front end
engagements with your patients.
Number two is eliminating long hold times
and inefficient activity.
So with a combination of, you
know, shortening workforce,
but also long or more call volumes
that are coming into the healthcare space,
this really is a recipe for
potential bad experience.
So how do we leverage AI to
enable self-service capabilities
and drive down this call volumes,
but at the same time, give
your caregivers better tools
with AI that allow them to
service patients faster.
And then number three is
reducing the complexity around
how care is delivered, right?
So today in a modern
healthcare, you know, scenario,
you may have follow up
appointments, you may have
to coordinate different care specialists,
and sometimes you just
don't know where to go
to get help when you need it.
And so we can leverage AI
to look at this from a holistic view
and be a, you know, kind
of like that shepherd
and guiding them in a
smart way to make sure
that they're following along
and we can avoid scenarios like
non-adherence and readmission.
So Sunil, any thoughts there?
- I'll dive into how this
patient journey unfolds
on the next slide.
So if you really think
about the patient journey
whether it's for a short episode of care,
like going for a cold,
or a longer therapy,
like a cancer therapy,
there are some distinct steps.
There are the patients,
there is an intake process,
they communicate what they're
going through, they need
to get their appointments.
Then there is the actual visit
part, which can be virtual
or in person.
And then there's a post care follow up.
And then there is the nurturing campaigns
and continuous engagement,
proactive communications.
When you think about this,
on the front end, the point
where the patients come
in, that ingress point,
that's where you can
collect a lot of information
and provide that high
bar customer experience
that they deserve.
And this can be done by
having natural language AI
powered by Lex as well as Noah Sonic now
to try and provide
self-service opportunities.
Where is parking, what
are the hours of operation
I need to set an appointment?
These things can be managed
automatically if you can deflect
40% of the volume as many
customers have achieved,
what that does is it takes
the load off your engagement
platforms and your agents don't have to
provide answers to routine interactions.
They can focus their energy
and effort on the high
complexity, high value interactions.
Let's actually see a demo to,
and this is an immersive
demo, so I would encourage you
to listen to it carefully.
There are a lot of things going on
and you can see what that next
level engagement looks like.
- Yeah, before we jump
into the demo real quick.
So for those in the audience
who are not familiar
with Amazon Connect, this is
a full-blown contact center
as a service platform that
was built for Amazon by Amazon
and it was commercially
available back in 2017,
but now has grown very
quickly to be a leader
in the contact center space as defined
by folks like Gartner.
So it's an entire end-to-end application.
So from a patient experience perspective,
you have the full omnichannel
opportunities of integrate,
of calling in through voice, chat, SMS,
video, in-app web calling.
You can also integrate, you
know, agentic framework,
agentic chatbots and conversational AI.
If you need to elevate
that call to an agent,
agents have unified workspaces
where you can integrate
all of your applications
that are necessary
to reduce contact switching
and also your knowledge
library that allows you
to get next best action in order to solve
the inquiry faster.
From a supervisor perspective,
you have, you know,
all the reporting options
that you would need.
So whether it's out of the
box or you can customize them,
but also there's a lot of
tools that are available
to supervisors that
reduce a lot of the time
that goes into QA for your agents.
So this really helps on the front
of getting them more efficient,
training them faster,
improving them faster, but
really improving that time
to value for somebody that's
new to the organization.
And then finally, from an
administrator standpoint,
it's a simple, intuitive
GUIs when it comes
to designing your contact center,
but also making changes on the fly.
And then finally the modern API and SDK.
So what you'll see here in a
second on our demo is you can
leverage these APIs
and SDKs to really curate the experiences
that you're looking to
create for your customers.
And you know, I'll quickly say too,
that the two advantages that we see
with Amazon Connect in the
field is that is the modularity
and the consumption based model.
And modularity, what
I mean by that is that
you don't have to adopt the
entire platform all upfront.
There's no upfront investment
and there's no licensing tiers
that you have to worry about.
You truly pick the services that align
to your organization's needs
and you go and build those,
and then the consumption
model allows you to pay for
what you truly use.
So with proper finops,
you know, practices,
you can really achieve high ROIs
when adopting Amazon Connect.
So with that, we're gonna walk you through
a quick little demo on
what this new experience
could look like.
(phone line ringing)
- [Speaker] Thank you
for calling Any Health.
I'm your virtual assistant.
Our system recognizes this number.
Am I speaking to Juan?
- [Juan] Hey, yes, this is Juan.
- [Speaker] Hi Juan.
Let me quickly verify your
identity before we go further.
I've sent a one-time code to
your registered phone number.
Can you please read it to me?
- [Juan] Sure. It's 547099.
- [Speaker] Thanks.
Could you also confirm your date of birth?
- [Juan] August 1st, 1984.
- [Speaker] Thank you for verifying, Juan.
Our records show you're
a designated caregiver.
Are you calling today
about Terri Whitlock?
- [Juan] Yes, I am.
- [Speaker] Okay, I see your
mom was recently discharged
from our hospital on August 15th.
Dr. Williams, as part of
her discharge care plan,
recommended an EKG follow-up appointment.
Would you like to schedule
that appointment now?
I can help you find a convenient time.
- [Juan] That'd be great.
- [Speaker] Based on your
previous scheduling preferences
for Terri's appointments,
I see you typically choose
Friday afternoons.
I have the following slots available
with Dr. Smith on Friday, August 22nd.
1:00 PM, 2:30 PM or 3:45 PM
at the Any Health Maine medical offices.
Don't worry about writing us down,
I'll send all the details
including the address
in your appointment confirmation email.
Would any of these times work for you?
I can also check other days if you prefer.
- [Juan] 1:00 PM Sounds good.
- [Speaker] Perfect.
I'll schedule Terri's EKG appointment
with Dr. Smith for Friday,
August 22nd at 1:00 PM at the Any Health
Maine medical offices.
And Juan, since this is a new
specialist visit for Terri,
would you like me to quickly
check if the existing referral
from Dr. Williams fully
covers this consultation?
Or if any additional
authorization might be needed from
Terri's primary care physician, Dr. Chen?
Sometimes different insurance plans
have specific requirements.
- [Juan] That's a good point.
Yes, if you could check.
- [Speaker] Sure. Just one moment.
Okay, I've reviewed Terri's
current authorization status.
It appears the referral from
Dr. Williams is comprehensive
and covers this initial
consultation with Dr. Smith.
So no further action should
be needed from your end
regarding authorization for this visit.
- [Juan] Great, for this
appointment, is there anything
specific that Terri
needs to do to prepare?
- That's a thoughtful question, Juan.
Let me check the standard
preparation guidelines
for a new patient cardiology
consultation with Dr. Smith.
Mary should continue taking
all her current medications
unless specifically instructed otherwise.
Wear comfortable clothing, bring a list
of her current medications, not eat
or drink anything except water
for four hours before the appointment.
- [Juan] That's a lot of instructions.
Can you send these to me somehow?
- [Speaker] Don't worry, I'll
include all these preparation
guidelines in your
appointment confirmation email
for easy reference.
Would you also like me
to text this to you?
- [Juan] Yes, please.
- [Speaker] The instructions
have been texted to you.
Additionally, you'll receive
appointment reminders
as we get closer to August 22nd.
Is there anything else I
can help you with today?
- [Juan] No, that's all.
- [Speaker] Thank you
for calling Any Health.
Have a great day.
- Excellent.
So I hope everybody was able to hear it.
If not, you could read some of the subtext
that were up there.
But you know, again,
this demo really shows
how you can take an average interaction
and really transform that experience,
leveraging all the
capabilities that come out
of the box with Amazon Connect.
And really, when you're thinking about it,
you're not looking at
it from the lens of as a
contact center, you're truly looking at it
as a patient engagement platform.
And so for the interest of
time, I won't be able to go
through all these, but
you know, these are a lot
of the common themes and
benefits we're seeing
with customers adopting
this type of strategy.
And you could see quite a few
of these in that demo alone.
So enhancing patient member engagement
through omnichannel communication.
The patient called in
through a voice channel,
but they spoke with the conversational AI
and they also interacted
over text message.
So it's a seamless unified
omnichannel experience
that the customer enabled.
You're leveraging AI and
automation for personalized care.
The conversational AI in the
background was interacting
with key systems like your EHR
to understand who they were,
why they were calling, what
they could be calling about,
but also hook into other
systems for prescription refills
or appointment scheduling.
So being able to leverage
that can create a contextual
but seamless experience for them.
And then finally, to
streamline administrative
and operational processes, right?
So these context center
platforms like Amazon Connect,
they have sophisticated
IVRs where you can embed
a lot of the, your simple tasks
that take up a lot of time
for your caregivers, such
as, you know, bill payment
or patients or rescheduling appointments.
You can streamline all of
this in the IVR to provide
a better experience for that
patient that's calling in,
but B, again, giving time
back to your caregivers.
So again, this is really the strategy
of how we're seeing customers adopt,
taking it from a contact center,
but thinking about it from
an engagement platform
and really rethinking
those new experiences.
So Sunil, walk us through on, you know,
how would we get started in
implementing the strategy?
- The big challenge customers
face is the patient engagement
journey is very complicated.
There are many parts of the organization
interacting with the patients.
Where do customers really start?
And the answer is they can start anywhere.
Amazon Connect is
engineered for the future
to accommodate all
kinds of AI, agentic AI,
conversational AI,
predictive AI, generative AI.
And the important thing is
that customers can choose
the extent and pace at which they bring AI
into their organization.
So if you look at this
slide, it's pretty busy,
but if you think of the
top half of the slide,
that's the fastest way
to go modernize your
patient engagement journeys.
On the top left, you'll see
that you can improve the IVR
like you experienced in the demo.
It was providing
self-service opportunities,
natural language used by
powered by Lex, Noah Sonic
and Agentic workflows.
I would highly encourage you,
on Thursday there's a session
by University of California
San Diego where they talk about
how they were able to
leverage Amazon Connect
and agentic workflows
to improve the self-service opportunities,
have patient verification
improve the first call resolution
and reduce the average handle time.
The right hand side of this slide
shows the outbound campaigns.
There's a need to proactively
reach out to customers.
One excellent example is
Jupiter Medical Center.
They had a peculiar problem.
They have this expensive
radiology equipment
that was used only about 75%
of the time, yet they had a lot
of open referrals for radiology.
They used Amazon Connect
outbound campaigns
to proactively reach out to those patients
and they were able to
convert a lot of them into
actual appointments.
The capacity utilization
of this expensive equipment
went up from 75% to 95%.
Think about what that means.
Number one, more revenue.
Number two, the productivity
of those expensive technicians is higher.
And most importantly,
patients get the imaging
that they need so that
they can have the diagnosis
and the treatment that
they deserve and need.
So it's a trifecta of benefits.
The bottom half of this slide shows
traditional contact centers.
One hidden opportunity is in
the clinics and departments.
You think of any healthcare
system, the departments,
ambulatory centers and clinics.
A lot of conversations
happen between the patients
and those clinics directly.
And yet there are these old style phones
that are not AI ML powered devices.
You can deploy Amazon
Connect there, take advantage
of the agentic workflows
and all of the goodness.
And the best part is
because it's a consumption based model,
it's not a license based model,
even in those low volume locations,
overall, individually they're low volume,
but together they contribute
a high volume of interactions.
You can deploy Amazon Connect.
Ed, do you want to take it next
and explain how Kyndryl has
deployed Amazon Connect?
- Yeah, so I chose this scenario
because it was something
that we deployed earlier in the year
and it really just kind of
speaks to everything that Sunil
and I are talking about, right?
You can adopt at your own
pace, but really start with
the workflows or start with
the needs that matter most
to your organization.
So, you know, when a federal
government COVID era program
wound down around safety
net benefit programs,
all of the constituents of
the state had to re-enroll
at the state level.
And the infrastructure that
was in place was not able
to really hold up to the
volumes that were coming in.
And undoubtedly what led next was,
you know, bad experiences.
People were on hold for two plus hours,
sometimes more than four hours.
They weren't happy, agents
were burning out very quickly.
So the agency knew they
had to make a change
and really figure out how
to leverage technology
to solve a lot of the issues
that they were facing.
And so we helped design a new
system that spoke to a lot
of the self-service needs
that they were requiring.
This was around, you know,
checking the status of,
you know, how much money is on my card,
when's my next benefit coming through,
are there other benefits
that I may be entitled to
and many more other use cases.
And what it led to,
initially in the first month
of deploying this was 30% call deflection,
which was amazing.
Also, there was a self-service capability,
so that meant when the
hours of this department
or the call center was closed,
people could still go in
and ask critical questions,
especially around
how much entitlements
may be on their cards.
So it was a big win.
The NPS scores were starting to improve,
the agents were much happier,
and because of the amount
of data they were able
to collect in the IVR about the
caller, the agents were able
to quickly reduce how much
time it took to handle
a lot of the inquiries
that were coming through.
So, and a great partnership with AWS,
they've been fantastic in
helping support us along
that journey along with
the client as well.
So Sunil, let's take us
home, keys to success.
- The first basic thing is
making the decision to move
to a cloud-based patient
engagement solution
like Amazon Connect.
Because if you don't move to the cloud,
you cannot take advantage
of all the data AI,
the continuous interactions
that your patients are having,
being able to personalize
the experiences to them
and understand their context.
So that's the first step.
The second step is crawl, walk, run.
It can be pretty overwhelming
if you try to plan
this whole journey and try to
massively change your system.
The trick is to find those
opportunities, like I explained,
those IVR modernization as
well as the outbound campaigns
are good places to start
because you'll get the ROI,
you'll have savings and you
can then pool those savings
into modernizing other
parts of your system.
The third part is choosing
the right partner.
Kyndryl's a great partner, lot
of experience in healthcare
and Amazon Connect, and people.
Getting your people in the
journey is very important
because they have institutional knowledge,
they know the inside of your organization
and when they work with the partner
and AWS technology, they are
going to uplevel their skills
and be ready for the future
so that they can deploy agentic workflows,
not only on the front end,
but then take it downstream
through all the organizational processes,
including clinical workflows.
- And we're right at time,
so I'll quickly go
through these last ones,
but you know, Kyndryl,
we've invested heavily
in the healthcare space.
We have over 13,000 practitioners,
whether they're supporting
our existing clients
or they're involved in our
consulting organization.
We've been investing
heavily in our partnerships
with Epic, Oracle, Ovation.
And we've been recognized as
a healthcare IT services firm
by, you know, three independent,
third party advising organization.
So, you know, this is an
area we take very, you know,
very seriously and we continue
to invest heavily into this space.
So yes, we do connect,
but we do a lot of other
things in the healthcare arena
as well.
And with that, we really appreciate
everybody coming by today.
Thank you for your time and
spending with us, and Sunil
and I are happy to hang out around
and answer any questions you may have.
Thank you.